bienvenidos de nuevo jajaja seguramente
te asuste y es que hoy tengo mucha
energía y estoy de una manera muy rápida
espero no irme tan rápido en estos
vídeos pero pero y bueno es que
realmente no me gustaría aturdir t con
mi vida personal pero te voy a contar
hoy me prepararon una comida deliciosa
una de mis comidas favoritas y eso me
dio mucha energía es increíble bueno tal
vez piensas que estoy un poco loco pero
en fin regresemos a los vídeos de ese
arte este es el nuevo vídeo del s
estamos en el problema número 15 así que
vamos con todo el ánimo a resolver este
problema que dice así tenemos este
triángulo p q r aquí es p y es un
triángulo equilátero eso es lo que me
dice el problema después dice si la
recta s r y la recta
en la recta tv se interceptan en el
punto p entonces cuánto vale james lo
que queremos saber es el valor de james
y bueno si te das cuenta ya hice este
dibujo para que tú tengas más tiempo y
no pierdas tiempo en lo que yo dibujo
este triángulo o esta cosa rara que
tenemos aquí yo valoro mucho tu tiempo
así que vamos a resolver este problema y
para eso voy a cambiar de color si éste
el triángulo p q r es un triángulo
equilátero entonces lo que sabemos es
que sus lados miden lo mismo y sus
ángulos también este ángulo mide 60
grados este de aquí va a venir 60 grados
también y este de aquí todo éste va a
medir 60 grados todo esto de aquí va a
medir también 60 grados
aquí tenemos mis tres ángulos de un
triángulo equilátero y todos miden lo
mismo pero además sabemos que este
ángulo de 60 grados se está dividiendo
en tres partes está
esta y ésta y los tres partes son
iguales las tres valen x por lo tanto
cada una de estas vale 20 grados voy a
dividir 60 entre 3 y me da 20 este
también es de 20 grados y este también
es de 20 grados muy bien ahora yo lo que
quiero saber es el valor de james y para
sacar el valor de james vamos a
visualizar con mucho cuidado cuáles son
las dos rectas que se intersectan para
ver entonces de quién es opuesto y deben
de afectar esta recta de aquí está de
por aquí perfecto con esta otra de cam
esta otra recta de por acá estas dos
ramas que se va a interceptar entonces
recordando un poco lo que hemos visto
acerca de ángulos opuestos este ángulo
este de aquí va a ser opuesto a estos
dos si te das cuenta se intersectan mis
dos rectas y por lo tanto estos dos
ángulos son iguales
james es igual a x más x es decir a 2x
por lo tanto
es igual y aquí tengo x x es decir 20
grados más 20 grados son 40 grados así
de fácil y así de sencillo estaba este
problema así que déjame ver si aquí me
cabe el problema número 16 vamos a
resolver aquí el problema número 16 y
dice y está genial estos problemas me
encantan 7 bien lo que dice dice si a
triángulo b a triángulo b significa que
es a más 3 b esto es lo que nos dan y
por otra parte a cuadrado b a cuadrado b
esto es igual a am más 4 b entonces si
nosotros nos tomamos 4 triángulo 5 james
igual a 5 james cuadrado 4 lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale james y bueno
lo padre de este asunto es que aquí ya
tenemos definidas las podríamos decir
las funciones de dos variables triángulo
y cuadrado porque al final son funciones
ya que tenemos definido a que es
equivalente tener un triángulo ya que es
equivalente tener un cuadrado así que
vamos a utilizarlo yo lo que quiero
saber es cuánto es cuatro triángulos 5m
pero en la función triángulo dice pones
a amd a estos que está antes del
triangulito que es 4 pongo el 4 y a esto
le sumó tres veces b b es el que está
después del triangulito así que en este
caso 5 james vale de entonces más 3
veces ven pero ve vale 5 veces y esto me
dice que es igual a 5 y cuadrado 4
entonces vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa
con
cuadrado el primer término antes del
cuadrado se llama y por lo tanto 5 g se
llama am y hay que ponerlo tal cual 5 y
ya esto cuadrado 4 por lo tanto en este
caso 4 vale b ya este 4 hay que
multiplicarlo por 4 es decir 5 y más 4 b
pero ve en este caso vale 4 entonces 4 x
4 y qué crees aquí ya tengo una ecuación
con una incógnita lo único que tenía que
hacer era saber leer estas funciones que
tengo aquí la función triángulo la
función cuadrado y así substituir 4 y 5
y entonces ahora sí vamos a ver que nos
quedan tengo 4 más 3 x 5 es 15 james
esto es igual a 5 james + 4 x 4 estos 16
muy bien y vamos a resolver la am
creo que me cabe por acá tengo 4 más 15
esto es igual a 5 y 16 ahora voy a pasar
este 4 del otro lado y me va a quedar
que 15 james es igual a 5 y más 16 menos
4 entonces estos dos se pueden reducir y
me queda que 15 james es igual a 5 james
+ 12 y ahora voy a pasar este 5 y de
este lado como restando 5 y de ambos
lados de la ecuación de tal manera que
me queda 10 bien de este lado 15 menos 5
james y de este otro lado se va el 5
james y solamente me queda 12 es decir
que james es igual a 12 entre 10 lo cual
es lo mismo que 6 quintos si yo saco
mitad arriba y mitad abajo dividiendo
entre 2 arriba y entre 2 abajo llegó a
que el valor de este problema número 16
es 6 quintos estos problemas me encantan
cuando tienen cosas raras como
triángulos o cuadrados y te definen aquí
que significa tener un 3
o un cuadrado o cualquier otra función
así que bueno borremos todo esto y vamos
a hacer el siguiente problema borremos
todo esto y vamos a hacer ahora el
problema 17 que dice lo siguiente en el
plano xy en la función x igual y
cuadrada menos 4 vamos a ponerlo aquí la
función x igual al cuadrado menos 4
interceptan a la recta el en esta va a
interceptar a la recta l en los puntos
siguientes en el punto cero p y en el
punto 5 combate en el punto 5 combate y
lo que nos preguntan es cuál es el valor
máximo que puede tomar la pendiente de l
cuál es el valor máximo que puede tomar
mi pendiente de l
y como respondemos esto bueno no es
necesario que tú hagas la gráfica por la
cuestión del tiempo en tu examen de ese
arte sin embargo me gustaría hacer aquí
una pequeña gráfica para que veas cómo
está este problema así que vamos a
dibujar los dos ejes voy a decir que
este es un eje este es mi otro eje y mi
función mi función
x igual a ye cuadrada menos 4 en primer
lugar pasa por aquí por el menos 4 así
que voy a decir que este es mi valor de
menos 4 y si te das cuenta es una
función cuadrática solamente que
nosotros estamos acostumbrados a las
funciones y es igual a una función de x
pero bueno aquí tenemos a x expresada
como una función de james y esta es una
función más o menos así
se abre para acá y por otra parte se
abre por acá muy bien y entonces me
dicen que yo tengo una cierta recta
llamada l que cruza en los puntos 0 p y
que cruza en otro punto llamado cinco
centros voy a suponer que es como por
aquí y vamos a hacer una recta que pase
por estos dos puntos esta recta pasa por
esos dos puntos y le voy a llamar mi
recta l muy bien entonces si esta recta
pasa por este punto y pasa por este
punto
quiere decir que comparte puntos con
esta función x igual a cuadrada menos 4
pero además yo sé los valores de x yo sé
que x vale cero y que x vale 5 así que
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa cuando x
vale 0 si x vale cero entonces me
quedaría que 0 es igual al cuadrado
menos 4 y de aquí puedo despejar
si yo paso este 4 del otro lado me queda
que 4 es igual al cuadrado y de aquí voy
a obtener que james es igual a más menos
2 la raíz cuadrada de 4 es más menos 2
esto si x vale 4 en el primer caso
entonces p puede ser más menos 2 muy
bien ahora qué pasa si nosotros tenemos
que x sea igual a 5 si x vale 5 entonces
me quedaría que 5 es igual al cuadrado
menos 4 y de aquí si sumo cuatro de
ambos lados me va a quedar que 9 es
igual al cuadrado
o dicho otra manera y es igual a más
menos 3 entonces en este caso si x vale
5 te puede tomar el valor de más menos 3
y así ya tenemos mucho más fácil la idea
de cuánto vale pd cuánto vale t y no
tenemos porqué estresarnos tanto y ya
tenemos una idea numérica por lo tanto
es mucho más fácil que verlo de una
forma abstracta
ahora yo lo que quiero es el valor
máximo que pueda tomar la pendiente de
él y quiero que te des cuenta de lo
siguiente los valores de x ya están
predestinados 0 y 5 por lo tanto abajo
mi pendiente que es una diferencia de
puntos los valores de x de esta
pendiente ya los tenemos fijos es 5 y 0
lo que podemos modificar son los valores
de tiempo tomar más 2 menos dos o más
tres y menos tres pero si te das cuenta
el valor más grande que podría tomar mi
pendiente sería la diferencia más grande
entre estos dos valores y la diferencia
positiva más grande entre estos dos
valores es tomarme al 3 positivo ya esto
quitarle pues el 2 pero negativo es
decir menos 2 si yo me tomo esta
diferencia es la diferencia más grande
que puede haber entre estos dos valores
y por lo tanto va a ser mi pendiente más
el valor máximo que puede tomar mi
pendiente 3 - 2 y abajo 5 - 0 y 3 -
menos 2 estos dos se convierten en
positivos y me queda tres más dos lo
cual es 5 y abajo me queda 5 -0 lo cual
es 5 y esto es igual a 1
entonces el 5 se habían puesto el 0 está
bien puesto y 1 es la pendiente más
grande que puede tomar mi recta l así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo